[Music]
okay that's strong space
she's too close I'm not going to get out
of here this
and stay oriented forward the person is
coming forward right but okay now I
don't want to stick out this
you gotta think that there's a groove
see see between her chin and her
shoulder pity
hitting strike you don't do that
you run into things so make a channel
for your arms you're not stopped at all
because you're trying to end up here but
it would be like Nate coming over here
and he sticks his hand right there you
see
and I tried good so make sure you turn
them into that group the arm can go
right into that
hey we know fine magnifying but is it
not the same they connected stay
accepting and keep the center counter
waiting the top and bottom of your body
don't do anything and it'll be fine
center line right
[Applause]
I'm doing one thing but he's doing
something else closely right hey he's
smooth he's behind like get that he has
connection he knows who's around them
what by him how do you let yourself
looks different from long without the
slightest bit of modern awareness and to
some level of repulsion some level that
shows some motivation to move toward
where they do not repulse in some way at
your distance to the model why don't you
go after too much acceptance where he
talk too much I'll get it next week I'll
get it next year he'll that up sooner or
later
what the hell do you think that is
really gonna change you that will not it
will not